marine le pen sarkozy hollande sont
finalement tous d'accord pour mener une
campagne sur le terrain du terrorisme de
l'immigration de l'identité nationale
c'est une campagne qui est démagogique
et là vous estimez collante c'est la
trahison de la maison tout ce travail
regardez sarkozy va regarder les
programmes regarder comment ça se passe
en fait on a quoi on a séduction
élections trahison parks est peut-être
une ministre de l'environnement heureuse
mais peut-être parce que vous n'avez pas
lu le livre de 800 est pas non plus une
interview de même du saut dans paris
match cette semaine
qui dit que vous êtes réduite à
l'impuissance je répond pas aux attaques
qui sont sans fondement tout ce qui ne
centre pas dans la réalité vite emportés
par les vents ici les gens savent que
quand le vent souffle on peut partir
loin donc moi je trace en effet un
sillon dans dans la durée visite
il faut que tu sois fière du lot et il
fera révolue dit voulu conseillé d'être
candidat ce que je lui dis ça me regarde
oui mais et encore une fois c'est à lui
de se déterminer qui dit si j'y vais
c'est pour gagner ça veut dire que a
priori il n'ira pas s'ils pensent qu'ils
ne gagneront pas ce que je pense qu'on
peut gagner
moi je dis qu'il n'est pas bon dans une
démocratie même si chacun est libre
qu'un ancien président de la république
revienne se représente pas ce que dans
aucune autre démocratie au monde ça ne
se passe comme ça on renouvelle les
générations pour que la propose un
programme qui est une sorte de retour en
arrière c'est qui c'est le président
sarkozy qui veut en gros refaire ce
qu'on a fait en 2007 il y avait des
choses intelligentes qu'elle est dans le
bon sens mais qui sont à mon avis
absolument pas à la hauteur de la
difficulté que notre pays rencontre et
alain juppé qui considère qu' on a le
temps que la france est un pays fragile
qu'il faut faire les choses doucement
une gauche et une droite qui n'assument
pas leurs convictions
un système politico est le politiquement
correct et par dessus tout une bonne
humeur
nous encore une république de justice
qui ouvre des chances égales pour tous
nous sommes nous prêts pour les
régressions les ralliements au nom d'une
restauration d'un ordre ancien parti de
gauche à deux doigts d'un peu de centres
vrai que c'est pourquoi il nous d'or
incolore et sans saveur
à l'arrivée vous aurez l'exploit mais
bon le cieux voilà qu'à parler de votre
douceur aussi je tiens absolument à
garder cette séquence là dans le montage
séoul et vient d'où ça c'est pas
forcément une île d yeu qualité
principale si le mec a été principal
bien sûr c'est différent mais ça n'est
pas forcément la première qu'on prête un
père français a demandé à son fils de 10
ans debby chan
que veux tu faire quand tu seras grand
palais le garçon lui a répondu divine
tigran être une fille ça je regrette
cette parole pour le moins légère et
infondées je vois qu'il aura été lui
aussi victime de la campagne de
désinformation massive conduite par les
intégristes la fondation lejeune vigie
gène d'heure et d'autres avoir des
tendances homosexuelles ou changer de
sexe est une chose mais faire un
enseignement dans les écoles sur cette
ligne pour faire changer les mentalités
c'est de la colonisation idéologique
je conseille au pape lors de l'un de ses
prochains déplacements en france de
venir à la rencontre d'enseignants de
l'école française tout simplement et
puis discuter avec eux de feuilleter lui
même ses manuels scolaires ses
programmes et de m'expliquer en quoi il
y aurait une théorie du genre qui
n'existent pas par ailleurs dans ses
livres les règles de la primaire à
gauche sont fixés et semble convaincre
un nouveau candidat s'est déclaré il
s'agit est d'arnaud montebourg
modalités sont très simples sont celles
de la dernière fois être pressé dans le
primaire 5% du conseil national ou des
élus pour pouvoir se présenter
et puis on devrait tourner aux alentours
de 8 à 9000 bureaux de vote qui ont la
primaire de la gauche il y aura votre
ancien collègue donc que françois de
rugy
c'est là la place des écologistes non
non non parce que l'écologie sortira
aussi congrue et sort et qu'elle l'est
aujourd'hui au gouvernement
l'objectif numéro 1 de montebourg c'est
de faire la peau de hollande
moi ça ne m'intéresse pas tous à 100 je
monte de pression d'âge qui sort qui
sort aujourd'hui et qui donnent hollande
à 48 % derrière montebourg à 52% pépère
à ne serez plus des capsules et il
serait siphonner marque pour la première
fois lors d'une élection présidentielle
la liste des parrains sera dévoilée en
temps réel sur le site du conseil
constitutionnel et le nom de chaque
signataire sera mentionnée pour les
présidentielles précédentes seuls 500
par un tirés au sort et est divulgué une
transparence à l'extrême
décrié par les petits partis parce qu'il
ya eu une loi qui a été votée un peu en
catimini pour durcir les règles qui
permettent de se présenter à l'élection
présidentielle nom n'est pas dupe
pas du tout dit de la manoeuvre de la
manière dont ça a été fait vous savez
dans tous les camps il ya des gens qui
de temps en temps des choses
intelligentes même dans ma famille
politique
ah c'est vrai mais pourtant une sautée
personnes non mais non parce que de
temps en temps mais il fallait un plan
pour sauver alstom ce matin christophe
sirugue le secrétaire d'état à
l'industrie est venu annoncer le plan
gouvernemental aux principaux intéressés
l'état s'engage à acheter à sa charge
quinze rames de tgv pour un coût de 450
millions d'euros
elles rouleront sur des lignes
intercités et quelques mois de la
présidentielle ont fait n'importe quoi
alors tant mieux tant mieux pour les
gens de belfort et c'est vraiment une
solution industrielle incroyable qu'on
voit que le gouvernement est dans le
bricolage
électoral voire électoralistes il a
fallu à tout prix trouver une solution
cette solution aider quand même bancale
c'est comme si demain airbus était en
difficulté et qu'on demande à hope qui
l'accompagnent régional d'air france
d'acheter des airbus a380 pour desservir
rodez lannion où agen ça n'est pas du
bricolage contrairement à ce que j'ai pu
entendre de la part d'un personnage très
important au niveau de l'état qui est
pas loin de moi de la part d'un ancien
ministre des transports monsieur
bussereau qui ne siège pas ici mais même
parfois dans les rangs de la majorité je
pense à monsieur hamon je regrette que
il faille la campagne présidentielle
pour que ce genre de décision
d'entreprise sur regrette le défaut
d'anticipation mais je me réjouis qu'une
décision soit prise qui préserve
l'emploi
on voit bien que rien n'est résolu en
catastrophe le gouvernement imagine une
commande plus ou moins artificiel qui va
repousser les échéances de quelques mois
mais qui ne règle pas le problème
structurel d'alstom vous devriez sur
tous les bancs vous réjouir du maintien
du site d'alstom
si j'arrive à 3 millions de plus j'aurai
des gens du centre
j'aurai des tissus du hollandisme
car quand on est de gauche quand ce
programme de gauche me semble assez
naturel de ne pas aller signer un papier
on sait qu'on est de droite et du centre
et la loyauté quand on appelle des
électeurs de gauche à venir faute et a
signé parjure un papier dans lequel il
s'engagerait à partager les valeurs de
la droite et du centre
alors qu'en vérité il n'en partagent
aucune vous allez soutenir la
candidature de bruno le maire à la
primaire des républicains marge
convaincu tueur je crois que tu paris
j'ai gagné la primaire un coq à parier
que j'ai fait choix du renouveau et de
l'homme qui défend le renouvellement de
la vie politique française par clos
maire il est pas vendeur
contrairement à celles offertes
face aux assauts
classique est superficiel de l'or les
choses devant son agora emmanuel macron
a évoqué plusieurs engagements la
proportionnelle au parlement ou encore
la limitation dans le temps du cumul des
mandats c'est vraiment faire du
soi-disant neuf avec du vieux avec des
paroles qu'on a déjà entendu avec des
propositions qu'on a déjà entendu primo
pour définir emmanuel macron vous
choisirez quelques sympathiques et avec
le sourire comme seul projet politique
pour aider aujourd'hui un cynisme à
visage souriant doublé d'un populisme
mondain ce que manuel valls appelle un
populiste light peut-on imaginer
sérieusement commander aux destinées du
pays ou même simplement se présenter aux
suffrages des français alors que sa
probité personnelle a été mise en cause
monsieur macron donne des leçons très
bien c'est son droit
vous savez ce qui arrive aux donneurs de
leçons en général ça leur revient dans
la figure
voilà si c'est ça la politique moderne
très bien car il a trahi la confiance il
a piétiné le gouvernement et les
caterpillar de la gauche qui l'a servier
qui a fait de lui un ministre de la
république parti j'avais quitté le
gouvernement pour aller rallier
quelqu'un qui était plus haut dans les
sondages
je pourrais vous vous êtes très haut
dans les sondages et vous menacer
françois hollande dans les sondages je
pourrais être un traître c'est ce qu'on
avait reproché à nicolas sarkozy quand
il avait quitté et croit jacques chirac
pour aller rejoindre monsieur balladur
est ce que je fais ça aujourd'hui
dans cette première l'instant mais pour
moi j'ai toujours été prête à tous les
ans je suis prête à tout avec lui c'est
une créature d'abord françois hollande
et ce système à l' oblique et quand on
est une créature de françois hollande de
dire qu'on va
tout changer je pense qu'il perpétuera
le système bien plus qu'il ne
transformera pas que jean marie le pen
attaque aujourd'hui en justice le parti
qu'il a créé et dont il a été exclu les
plus d'un an
il exige sa réintégration au fn ainsi
que des dommages et intérêts alors que
même les hommes politiques ont à coeur
et une situation comme celle-là peut
créer des chagrins évident mais une
passe derrière les nécessité absolue de
la vie politique quand on est dans la
politique on est au service du pays
pour vous la politique passe avant la
famille bien sûr que vous dites à jean
jacques bourdin si je fais la
présidentielle j'arrête la politique
exactement que c'est ce que j'ai fait
c'est à dire vous n' était pas arrêtée
pendant deux ans et demi si parfait j'ai
cru entendre l'avocat du mrap d'ailleurs
mais non c'était celui du front national
ainsi les oui qu'est ce que vous voulez
nous sommes tous décidés à ça et quand
nous partirons et vous aussi dans une
caisse en bois soit comme ça on n'en
peut plus de la tyrannie des caïds
dépendent des voleurs des voyous de la
racaille un certain nombre d'excès des
deux dérives de nicolas sarkozy nuisent
à la fonction marc cherry dirige ce soir
les gaulois la racaille
je trouve que l'épisode sur le burqini
ait été assez été assez vains et j'ai
trouvé la polémique sur les gaulois
c'est détestable
et si jeudi
des choses qui correspondent à ce que
pensent les français et s'ils jouent et
elle doit sur les vrais problèmes
je suis moi je suis à réalité des gens
vous pensez vraiment vous pouvez arriver
au second tour oui oui en tout cas c'est
pour ça que je suis candidate je suis
comblé mais je suis candidate pour une
écologie qui agit il n'est pas appelé
les électeurs de gauche à venir voter
non et appelé les français de bonne
volonté qui souscrivent aux valeurs
républicaines de la droite et du centre
ville je la conseille juste de lire le
détail votre probable programme
d'économies pour en parler dans une
maison vers et j'enverrai votre
témoignage à nicolas sarkozy via
n'importe quel petit américain
hutin être américain c'est la classe il
est fier
moi je voudrais que n'importe quel
français dans n'importe quelle école de
france se disputent un je suis français
sa classe par piété l'après-midi au
mondial de l'automobile et le soir aux
invalides pour la soirée attention un
gros mot valeurs actuelles
vous aller saluer monsieur buisson
président question pour cent vous avez
parlé à patrick buisson ce soir j'espère
que vous allez bien
ces vaisseaux
les assister oui ça qui est qui qui est
un système d'assistanat parfois dans
notre pays c'est la vérité oui
ayatollahs ça ces chiffres bruts madame
vallaud belkacem aurait bien fait se
taire elle nous fait on quand elle prend
à partie le pas marrer ce qui est
certain en revanche c'est qu'elle elle
fait pas du bien l'éducation nationale
est issue certaine manière c
c'est plus grave enfin c'est plutôt sain
problème pour ces lettres surprennent
tant par leur qualité littéraire que par
la passion dévorante de françois
mitterrand pour anne pingeot une liaison
de plus de 30 ans entamée au début des
années 60 sur la plage d'hossegor
je t'ai rencontrée j'ai tout de suite
deviné que j'allais partir pour un grand
voyage
je bénis ce visage ma lumière c'est
quand même françois mitterrand qui a
créé on ne connaît pas son visage à lui
dit si une femme que j'aime même alors
ou encouragent est immense et un enfant
qui se déclarent pour la première fois
candidat à la présidentielle on est loin
de tin d'heure